écoutez je peux vous faire de langue de
bois est évident que quand on prétend
arrivé au second tour et qu'on ne l'est
pas on l'est mais je pense surtout à mes
électeurs 1 et à tous les électeurs de
cette 3ème circonscription du doubs qui
sont front national ou qui sont à droite
et qui se sentent peut-être orphelins ce
soir donc c'est surtout et où je pense
sera déplacé chez niveau d'importance
finalement vous pensez y l'abstention
est très forte
oui j mendel tout à l'heure le dit ya
peut-être des électeurs même frontiste
qui d'habitude pourtant ce se mobilisent
assez fortement qui sont pas allés voter
alors il est vrai qu'on a pris la vague
en marche en plein sur nous avec cette
élection et on a vu en revanche dans le
département le département a voté un peu
plus que nationale et notamment dans
cette troisième circonscription du doubs
un tout petit peu plus que national en
tout cas ce que je retiens c'est que on
va devoir faire de meilleures campagnes
à l'avenir notre campagne n'a pas porté
ses fruits nous ne sommes pas au second
tour
mais l'implantation est sans doute la
clé c'est pour ça que je proposerai ma
candidature pour être le futur
secrétaire départemental du doubs il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire et est ce
que c'est une déclaration de guerre à
sophie montel ce soir parce qu'on sait
que le secrétaire départemental du doubs
c'est robert scène riche
le maire le mari le maire le mari de
sophie montel vous porter candidat ça
veut dire remettre en cause ses options
en ce moment je vous rappelle qu'il n'y
a pas de secrétaire départemental en ce
moment affirmé c'était l'ancien
secrétaire départemental
une place est vacante j'ai fait le choix
de faire une campagne forte pendant
cette élection et je vois que l'
enthousiasme ne retombera pas même si
nous sommes pas au second tour
il ya des gens dans tout le département
qui veulent qu'on fasse campagne et que
nos thèmes soient exploitées que les
électeurs se sentent représentés est ce
que vous estimez sur lignes différentes
est ce que vous estimez que la ligne
florian philippot puisque sophie montel
est une proche de florian philippot
n'est pas la bonne pour le front
national
je pense que c'est pas la question en
vérité nous sommes tous les deux au
front national
donc en revanche peut-être qu'après les
élections nous aurons toutes les
discussions en revanche est ce que
madame montel et pour l'immigration mais
je ne le pense pas est ce qu'elle est
pour la défense du droit des femmes
je le pense est ce qu'elle est pour la
défense de l'identité nationale je le
pense aussi
pour le ratio leurs règles et sur l'euro
et sur l'euro est ce qu elle a fait
campagne sur l'europe en dans cette
législative
ce n'était pas l'enjeu en tout cas donc
moi ce que je note c'est que en tout cas
ce qui est important puisqu'on va pas
passer des heures à parler de querelles
qui pourrait y avoir ou kylie a
peut-être c'est qu'en tout cas des vieux
crocodiles ont prétendu faire peau neuve
et on l'a vu dans cette troisième
circonscription du doubs avec notamment
monsieur denis sommer et donc les
électeurs trancheront
merci beaucoup louent vial et on va
partir